we've heard a lot about what's coming  back but there are some shows  that won't be caesar's entertainment  released a list of what will  and will not be returning just to name a  couple dionne warwick she is reportedly  focused on touring  and also the chippendales at the rio  they announced on twitter to stay tuned  though for future news  in a statement caesars entertainment  said while their run with our company is  now ending  we are grateful for their incredible  performances their many talented cast  and crew members and everything they  brought to our resorts and guests  we do have a full list of the changes  for you on 8newsnow.com